la merde non parce que tf1 page est
obligé d'animer à huy ne se valent pas
enfin paris tous les deux mais j'ai
perdu
ah bah justement regarder oui j'adore me
0,8
[Applaudissements]
et le pari le pari passants c'était si
tu perds d'être animé une émission de
tpm p c'est vrai alors ben on l'a fait
quand cette histoire ben on la fera au
moins une fois pour s'apercevoir si je
suis bon là dedans ou pas tué
non mais ça y est tu m'en suis une balle
et jouer je suis en chroniqueur a laissé
fait c'est dire attends tu crois que tu
[Applaudissements]
lui quand il fait tp alors laquelle tu
veux tu veux pas déclenché / l'argent là
on n'est pas avec ça c'est sale c'est
sale on n'aime pas ces salles on n'aime
pas trash dit arrête avec ça